GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S MONDAY MARCH
TWENTY FIRST. HIS PAST TWO
O'CLOCK. THE SENATE SESSION WILL
BEGIN WITH THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA
ATKINS BAIT BACKER BOARD JUST
BRADFORD COME BY ADAM CORTEZ
BEAN. VALLEY DOG THEY'RE ALSO A
GOOD MAN GLASER IS ALL S. GROVE
HURTS FOR WEST FOUND HER TADO.
JONES KAMMERER LAYERED LLEVA
LIMO WIRE MELINDA'S MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A TROUBLE TEN FOUR
TWENTY NOW RALPH RUBIO SKINNER
TURN ON BERG WHITE HOUSE SKI
WINNER WELL. THANK YOU MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. FOR THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY CENTER
MIKE POUNCEY AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. BY
SENATOR DOT. THE NEARBY CASKEY.
AS WE CONTINUE TO REMEMBER THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF WOMEN
THROUGHOUT THE CENTURIES TODAY
WE PRAY THE PRAYERS OF HILDEGARD
OF PAYING THEM WHO LIVED IN THE
TWELFTH CENTURY- INTERNAL LORD
IT IS PLEASING TO YOU TO BURN IN
THAT SAME FIRE OF LOVE THAT WAS
FROM. WHICH OUR BODIES ARE BORN
IN THE FIRST ON BEFORE ALL OF
THE CREATION TO CONSIDER THIS
NEED WHICH FALLS UPON US OUR
NEED FOR PEACE AND JUSTICE AND
RELIEVE US OF IT. AND LEND US
ENJOYS PROSPERITY- SHEPHERD OF
SOULS FROM WHOSE FIRST VOICE AND
THROUGH WHOM ALL CREATION WAS
SUMMONED NOW TO YOU MAY GIVE
PLEASURE INDIGNITY TO LIBERATE
US FROM OUR MISERIES AND ARE
LANGUISHING- LEAFY BRANCH
STANDING IN YOUR ABILITY AS THE
DAWN BREAKS FORTH. NOW REJOICE
AND BE GLAD IN TEAM TO US FRAIL
ONES FREE FROM EVIL HABITS AND
STRETCH FORTH YOUR HANDS AND
LIFT US UP WE ASK THIS IN YOUR
NAME A MAN. AND PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A PLEDGE TO OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. IS STRONG.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND GUESTS
WILL GROW TO NOW TWO MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR THEY WILL BE
DEEMED RED. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL REDEEM BREAD. IT'S
A COMMITTEE WILL MEETING DREAD
AND A MAINTENANCE ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
IS THERE ANY MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
OR NOTICES FROM THE BODY. SAYING
NINE MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK
OF MARCH FOURTEENTH TO THE
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
PROVED AND CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS WERE GONNA
MOVE TO THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE WE'RE GOING TO GO
FIRST TO SECOND READING
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. NFL
ELEVEN HUNDRED WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL. FOURTEEN NINETY
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO SENATE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHT THIRTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE BILL EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY NEXT
METHODOLOGIES GERMAN WE'RE GONNA
GO T UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE
HAVE ONE ITEM. AN UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WHICH WAS ITEM EIGHT.
CENTER GONZALEZ. ARE YOU READY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWO FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED GOOD
AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY OF TWO SP TWO FOUR FIVE
CONTAIN CLARIFYING LANGUAGE TO
FACILITATE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BILL BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
OF THINKING I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER I VOTE AND CONCURRENCE IN
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU CAN SIT AND CENTER GONZALEZ
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON ITEM
EIGHT ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR GORGEOUS. WE OFFER.
CENTER BARGES RECOGNIZED.
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR MUST
RESENT THERE IS ALSO YOU TAKE A
QUESTION. YES THANK YOU- SO THE
COPAY- THIS ALLOWANCE IS ONLY
FOR THESE TYPES OF MEDICAL
PROCEDURES IT DOESN'T COVER
OTHER PROCEDURES AS WELL. THE
CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE CENTER
IS ALSO GOING TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
AS THE TWO FORTY FIVE THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT IS CENTERED IN
SOLACE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA HI HOW CAN
I FACE. BACKER HI FOR JUST. NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW ARE YOU
PROTESTING I DALLY NO DOT. FIVE
ZERO SEVEN FIVE A GUNMAN. FIVE
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERZ BERG. WHERE ARE YOU HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR HI LYNN MON.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. NO MAN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A TROUBLED. NO
PAN I FORTINO RALPH I RUBIO. HI
SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER FIVE
CASSIE I WINNER I WILL. NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN I BASE NO. GROVE HERTZBERG
I HER TADO. LET ALONE I NIELSEN
. FORTINO STERN. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE HER TADO
NIELSEN FOUR TWENTY NOW. TURN.
HIGHS TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS IT'S
SEVEN THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE MOVING TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING AND FIRST
UP IS ITEM FIFTEEN WHICH IS
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NUMBER SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR
BATES SPINNERBAITS ARE YOU READY. SENATOR BATES IS READY
SECRETARY PLEASE REACH. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
ONE BY SENATOR BATES RELATIVE TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. INTERFACE THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
ONE NAMES MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AS TRAUMATIC TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSES FOR
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY INCLUDES
WORSE INJURIES CAR ACCIDENTS
FALLS FALLS AND WORKPLACE
ACCIDENTS AND CONTRIBUTES TO
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY PERCENT. OF
ALL INJURY RELATED DEATHS
ACCORDING TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA MEDICAL CENTER
SPORTS MEDICINE CONCUSSION
PROGRAM ABOUT 20% OF HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETES WHO PLAY CONTACT SPORTS
INCLUDING SOCCER SUSTAIN
CONCUSSIONS EACH YEAR. TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY CAN IMPACT A
PERSON'S COGNITION MOTOR SENSORY
COMMUNICATION ABILITY AND
EMOTIONAL HEALTH AS WELL AS
CAUSE LONG TERM NERO PSYCH
PSYCHIATRIC CONDITIONS THIS
ISSUE IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART AND I'M PROUD OF THE WORK
THAT OUR APPROACH HIM THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. YOU KNOW I WAS HORRIBLY
SO LONG WITH YOUR HELP TO
BRINGING A NEW INTREPID SPIRIT
CENTER TO CAMP PENDLETON IN MY
DISTRICT THE INTREPID SPIRIT
CENTER DIAGNOSES AND TREATS
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY TO
SERVICE MEMBERS WITH THE GOAL OF
ALLOWING THEM TO CONTINUE THEIR
REGULAR SERVICE IN THE ARMED
FORCES. AND TO ENSURE THEIR
LIVES CAN BE REWARDING AT WORK
AND AT HOME THE LONG TERM
EFFECTS OF TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURIES LARGELY DEPEND ON EARLY
DETECTION AND INTERVENTION
UNFORTUNATELY MANY TV EYES GO
UNDIAGNOSED WE DO NEED TO BRING
AWARENESS OF THE NEED FOR
SCREENING DIAGNOSIS AND
APPROPRIATE CARE. FOR THOSE WHO
SUSTAINED A HEAD INJURY AND
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
SUSTAINED A HEAD INJURY TO
DISCUSS IT WITH THEIR PHYSICIAN
S. C. R. SEVENTY ONE IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ATHLETIC TRAINERS ASSOCIATION
AND I RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR
I. BOAT. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA HI ACTIONS
ARE A FACE I BECKER I FORGES I
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T. HI
PROTESTING HI DOLLY I THOUGHT I
TORONTO I A COMMON. LASER FIVE
DOLLARS I GROW. HERTZBERG I WEAR
SO. HI HER TADO. HI JOHN. I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE ON. I
LOVE MY OWN HI WIRE I MELINDA'S
I MIN FIVE NEWMAN I NELSON I
TRIED BOTH I CAN HI FORTUNE TINO
. RALPH I RUBIO I SCANNER I
STERN. AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL I. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN I. ADMIN I GROVE FOUR
TWENTY NOW EARN. HIGHS THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED NEXT WE'RE GOING TO ITEM
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS SENATOR DODD
ON SENATE RESOLUTION NUMBER
SEVENTY. IF YOU'VE EVER SAID
IRAN TAKE JUST ONE SECOND A
BREAK HERE FOR JUST A MINUTE IF
YOU DON'T MIND WE HAVE A GUEST
IN THE GALLERY LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN. WE ARE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I BELIEVE THE LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE STATE.
AND THE NEW SUIT THE
SUPERINTENDENTS ALBERTO BARBA
LOT WHOLE. WELCOME SIR. WELCOME
TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
WE'RE HONORED THAT YOU'RE HERE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
NOW BACK TO THE FLOOR FOR
SENATOR DODD ON ITEM SEVENTEEN
CENTER DOT WILLBE PRESENTING S.
R. NUMBER SEVENTY. SECRETARY
PLEASE RE. SENATE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY BY SENATOR DODD RELATIVE
TO PROBLEM GAMBLING AWARENESS
MONTH CENTERED ON MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IS CHAIR OF THE SENATE
GOP MEATY I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION SEVENTY WHICH
RECOGNIZES MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AS PROBLEM GAMBLING
AWARENESS MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH MOST PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
GAMBLE RESPONSIBLY FOR SOME IT
BECOMES A DEVASTATING ADDICTION
THAT AFFECTS NOT ONLY THE
INDIVIDUAL BUT OF COURSE THEIR
LOVED ONES. FORTUNATELY GAMBLING
ADDICTION IS TREATABLE THAT IS
WHY THE MONTH OF MARCH- THAT
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE COME TOGETHER TO EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ABOUT THE WARNING
SIGNS A PROBLEM GAVE ME. THIS
RESOLUTION WILL RE RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE HELP THAT IS
AVAILABLE BOTH LOCALLY AND
NATIONALLY FOR PROBLEM GAMBLERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES I WANT TO
THANK EVERY SINGLE MEMBER OF THE
SENATE GOP COMMITTEE FOR CO
AUTHORING THIS RESOLUTION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'LL VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR DONALD ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- SENATORS
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR
SEVENTY ONE I THINK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM NAPA FOR BRAINS-
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
UP- THIS IS A PARTICULAR
CHALLENGE FOR THE ASIAN
AMERICAN. COMMUNITY WHERE THERE
ARE PERHAPS A- WHERE OFTENTIMES-
GAMBLING ESTABLISHMENTS- TARGET
OUR COMMUNITY AND- WE NEED TO BE
SURE THAT SUPPORTS ARE THERE-
FOR THE- ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WHEN IT COMES TO
PROBLEM GAMBLING. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RAISE AWARENESS OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES TO HAVE
MEMBERS THAT SUFFER FROM THIS-
IN THIS CHALLENGING PROBLEM.
WHICH CAN CERTAINLY DESTROY-
FAMILY PATIENTS CHIPS AND
FINANCIALS- THEIR FINANCES AND
SO FORTH SO AGAIN I- SUPPORT
PRESS OR SEVENTY ONE I THINK
MIGHT BE A GOOD PHONE NUMBER FOR
HER- INTERVIEWS RESOLUTION THANKYOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PANCER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF SR SEVENTY TO
RECOGNIZE MARCH. TWENTY TWO THE
PROBLEM GAMBLING AWARENESS
MONTH. GAMBLING ADDICTION IS AN
ADDICTION THAT JUST AS MUCH AS
ANY OTHER. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
ALL OF US HERE IN THE STATE
SENATE. RECOGNIZES AS AN
ELECTION TO SO MANY. IT IS SO
DETRIMENTAL TO SO MANY FAMILIES
ADDICTION TO GAMBLING HAS ALSO
BEEN SHOWN TO LEAD TO OTHER
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL ISSUES. IN
ADDITION TO THE UNDERLYING
GAMBLING PROBLEMS THAT AFFECTS
THE FAMILY. FORTUNATELY GAMBLING
ADDICTION IS TREATABLE IT'S A
TREATABLE DISEASE AND WITH HELP
GAMBLERS CAN GET THE HELP THEY
NEED. PROBLEM GAMBLERS HURT
THEMSELVES THEIR FAMILIES THEIR
COMMUNITIES AT LARGE. AND I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING AN SR
SEVENTY TO US AND RESPECTFULLY
AFTER I BOUGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR HELLO OF MEMBERS ANYMORE
DOES. OR TO. SEEING AND HEARING
SENATOR DODD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. VOTE THANK YOU SIR MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
CONSENT IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING AN UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
. SEEING NONE EYES THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MAJOR HAS BEEN
ADOPTED OR THE RESOLUTION
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN SENATOR
JONES MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION SEVENTY
TWO BY SENATOR JONES RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL SURVEYORS WEEK CENTER
JONES. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SR SEVENTY TWO
RECOGNIZES THE WEEK OF MARCH
TWENTIETH THE TWENTY SIX. AS
NATIONAL SURVEYORS WEEK LAND
SURVEYING HAS A PROUD HISTORY IN
THE UNITED STATES IN FACT SOME
OF OUR GREATEST AMERICANS HAVE
PERFORMED WORK HIS LAND
SURVEYORS. SUCH AS GEORGE
WASHINGTON ABRAHAM LINCOLN AND
HENRY DAVID THOREAU. THE WORK OF
LAND SURVEYORS DO IS ESSENTIAL
TO OUR SOCIETY FROM CONSTRUCTING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
DETERMINE GEOGRAPHICAL
BOUNDARIES REVOLVING DISPUTES
OVER LAND OWNERSHIP. I ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE TODAY ON S. R.
SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS ALSO
AVAILABLE- ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANYONE HAVE
ANY OBJECTION SEEING AND HEARING
NO NICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO AND
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM. YES SIR JONES
I'M SORRY I JUST HAD A QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENT WE HAVE SOME GUESTS
IN THE GALLERY FROM THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS AND
ALSO FROM THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES HERE
FOR THE RESOLUTION THANK YOU FOR
A KNOWLEDGE IN THEM AND WELCOME
THEM TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. VERY GOOD WELCOME
GENTLEMAN. ARE YOU IN THE MOOD
TO FILE AND I'M TWENTY TWO
SENATOR BORCHERS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. THAT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR BORJAS
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE DAY. THEIR BROWSER.
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES- AS CHAIRMAN
OF THE SENATE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE I AM HONORED TO
PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY THREE DECLARING THIS
WEDNESDAY MARCH TWENTY THREE AS
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE DAY
CALIFORNIA AG DAY RECOGNIZE IN
PEACE TRIBUTE TO ALL THOSE WHO
WORK IN THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY AND THEIR SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR EVERYDAY
LIVES. THOMAS JEFFERSON ONCE
DECLARED AND I QUOTE AGRICULTURE
IS OUR WISEST PURSUIT AS THE TOP
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCING STATE IN
THE NATION IT IS NOT ONLY
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AGRICULTURE'S VITAL ROLE IN
KEEPING CALIFORNIANS FED BUT
ALSO ITS ROLE IN KEEPING THE
NATION NOURISH ESPECIALLY AFTER
THE LESSONS OF COVERT NINETEEN.
IT IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT
RECOGNIZE BAGS CONTRIBUTION TO
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE OF THE
NATION INTERNATIONAL SECURITY
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIANS WORKING IN THE AG
INDUSTRY HELP FEED OUR NATION IN
STEPPED UP TO MEET THE HIGH
DEMAND FOR FOOD IN STORES
UNDERSCORING THE NEED TO PROTECT
OUR FOOD IN AG INFRASTRUCTURE
AND SUPPORTING INDUSTRIES. THE
FARM TO TABLE MOVEMENT HAS
BROUGHT ATTENTION TO THE FARM
INDUSTRY IN AWARENESS OF THE
COMPLEX SYSTEM INVOLVED IN
DELIVERING FOOD FROM THE FIELDS
TO OURTABLE. CALIFORNIA IS VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE HARD
WORKING FARMERS. AND FARM
WORKERS THAT PRODUCE OUR FOOD
AND AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
CALIFORNIA'S AG INDUSTRY IS A
VITAL PART OF OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY. THE AREAS OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND FOOTHILLS
WHICH I AM PROUD TO REPRESENT
ARE SOME OF THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IN THE WORLD.
IN CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND
RANCHERS ARE STEWARDS. OF TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ACRES OF LAND STATE
WIDE. CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION ACT PRODUCTION AND
EXPORTS WITH MORE THAN TWENTY
BILLION IN FOOD AND AG
COMMODITIES GLOBALLY. THE
STATE'S AG INDUSTRIES UNLIKE ANY
OTHER INDUSTRY IN THE NATION
CALIFORNIA PRODUCES MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED SPECIALTY CROPS 50%
OF THE NATION'S FRUITS
VEGETABLES AND NUTS IN LEADS THE
NATION IN SUSTAINABLE DAIRY
PRODUCTION. AS AG HAS EVOLVED
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO REMAIN
AT THE FOREFRONT FOR FRONT OF
THE INDUSTRY. OUR STATE'S VAST
CLIMATE AND FERTILE SOIL SOILS
HAVE CREATED AN INDUSTRY THAT
STANDS AS THE BACKBONE OF OUR
STATE AND NATION. SO COLLEAGUES
I INVITE YOU AND STAFF TO JOIN
ME THIS WEDNESDAY DAY AFTER
TOMORROW. ON THE WEST STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL STARTING AT TEN
THIRTY AM TO CELEBRATE THE
FARMERS RANCHERS GROWERS AND
LABORS ARE QUICK ME CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE WHAT IT IS TODAY.
THERE WILL BE FOOD IN CASE
ANYBODY'S WONDERING FARM
EQUIPMENT IN CASE OTHERS WERE
WONDERING LIVESTOCK IN PLENTY
MORE TO ENJOY AS SENATOR DELHI
HAD INQUIRED EARLIER. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
CALIFORNIA AG DAY WITHIN I. VOTE
ON S. OR SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
. SENATOR DELHI THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MR
PRESIDENT AS THE I BELIEVE THE
ONLY. ACTIVE FARMER- ON THE
FLOOR- WE I KNOW THAT TO SENATOR
. THE SENATOR FROM TO HEMA- IT
USED TO BE AN ACT AS WELL BUT I
WANTED TO JUST RISE AND HAS VERY
AWESOME THAT TO CALIFORNIA LEADS
THE NATION NOT ONLY IN A
PRODUCTION OF BAG. IT LEADS THE
WORLD IN TECHNOLOGY AND THE
SAFEST US FOOD SUPPLY IN THE
WORLD COMES OUT OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE THE MOST REGULATED.
INDUSTRY IN OUR STATE BUT WE
PRODUCE A HIGH QUALITY GRADES
SAFE PRODUCT FOR ALL AMERICANS
IN THE WORLD- PROVIDED
CALIFORNIA IS IT UNIQUELY.
DESIGNED WE HAVE THIS YEAR IS
WHAT WE CATCH THE SNOW FALL ON
MOST YEARS AT NOT THIS YEAR WE
ARE IN A SEVERE DROUGHT. BUT
THEN THE WATERS RUN DOWN IN THE
VALLEY AND- THE WATER IS USED
THROUGH AMAZING- INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE BUILT
OVER THE DECADES. TO- TO. WATER
OUR CROPS AND PRODUCE AMAZING-
COMMODITIES WE ALSO HAVE THE
PORCH WE CAN S. EXPORT. OUT OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE ARE THE
LEADING EXPORTER IN THE WORLD. I
JUST WANT TO- AS A FARMER IS
SAID MY FAMILY'S FARM FOR NINETY
THREE YEARS IN CALIFORNIA I'M
THE THIRD GENERATION- BUT IT'S
GETTING TOUGH TO STAY IN THE
STATE IN AGRICULTURE. I DO TOO
MANY CONSTRAINTS- LABOR- COST OF
A COMMODITIES FERTILIZER IS
QUADRUPLED THIS YEAR ALONE- DUE
TO THE SHORTAGE OF- NATURAL GAS
QUITE FRANKLY SO I JUST WANT YOU
TO COME OUT WEDNESDAY JOIN US-
THOSE OF US WHO ARE NAG IT'S A
GREAT DAY. AND YOU KNOW EVERY
DAY MOST PEOPLE THREE TIMES A
DAY NEED A FARMER BECAUSE
THEY'RE EATING AT LEAST THREE
TIMES A DAY. AND SO I'M JUST
PROUD TO BE ONE IN CALIFORNIA B.
ON THE SENATE. AND ASK YOU TO
JOIN US ON WEDNESDAY FOR THE-
BAG SUPPOSING THAT'S OUT THERE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
SENATOR DALLY ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
CAFIERO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SR
SEVENTY THREE WHICH RECOGNIZES
AND HONORS ALL WHO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE FOR THEIR
DEDICATION AND PRODUCTIVITY BY
OBSERVING MARCH TWENTY SECOND AS
NATIONAL AG AGRICULTURE DAY AND
DESIGNATING MARCH TWENTY THIRD
AS CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE DAY
FORMER OCCURS ARE THE HARDEST
WORKING INDIVIDUALS SHOWING UP
TO WORK RAIN OR SHINE THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR FOOD SAFETY
AND SECURITY AND ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR SUSTAINING CALIFORNIA'S
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY AND THE
PRODUCTION OF AMERICA'S FRESH
FOOD SUPPLY. CALIFORNIA PRODUCES
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED DIFFERENT
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITIES OVER
ONE THIRD OF THE COUNTRY'S
VEGETABLES AND TWO THIRDS OF THE
COUNTRY'S FRUITS AND NUTS BUT
JUST THINK ABOUT THAT IF
CALIFORNIA DIDN'T PRODUCE SOME
BEND TO THIRDS OF WHAT WE
CONSUME ON A ON A DAILY BASIS
WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE TO US THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS ONE OF THE
WORLD'S MOST PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL REGIONS THAT GROWS
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF COMMODITIES
OVER 99% OF CALIFORNIA'S TWELVE
HUNDRED DAIRY FARMS ARE FAMILY
OWNED. AND THE DAIRY SECTOR
SUPPORTS APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND JOBS IN OUR
STATE OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WORKING CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY FROM
FARMERS TO FARM WORKERS THE
WORKERS IN THE FOOD PROCESSING
AND CAT CANNERY INDUSTRY PLEASE
JOIN US IN SUPPORTING SR SEVENTY
THREE AND RECOGNIZE OUR WORKERS
INVOLVED IN PRODUCING PROVIDING
SUCH A BOUNTY TO OUR NATION. AND
TO THE ENTIRE WORK. THANK YOU
CENTER CALERO. MEMBERS ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SR
SEVENTY THREE ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
BARGES. I THINK WHAT MOST PEOPLE
WANT TO KNOW IS IF THERE'S GOING
TO BE HARD BOILED EGGS THERE
THIS YEAR LIKE NORMAL YOU MAY
CLOSE MR PURCHASE. RESPECTFULLY
AUSTIN I HOPE. THIS ITEM IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM
THING NO OBJECTION HIGHS THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE
NOW TO THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS TWENTY EIGHT
THROUGH THIRTY FIVE IS THERE ANY
MEMBER WISHING TO PULL AN ITEM
OFF OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE OF. 612-913-1130. TO ONE THIRTY THREE ONE FORTY
THREE ONE FORTY FIVE AND
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY SIX. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY IS COLORADO. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I HAD KITTENS I HATE
I. BECKER. FIVE FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI BYRON HI PROTESTING
I. DALI HI TODD. I DRAW SO I
EXAMINED BY GLAZER I WANT ALL OF
OUR GROWTH. PARTS FOR HI WEST SO
. HI HER TADO I JONES I CAN
WANDER. I LAYERED I LABOR HI THE
MON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S FIVE
MILLION FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN I
GO TO A VOTE HI PAM. I FOUR
TWENTY NINE BROCK I RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN NUMBER FIVE WHAT
KIND OF SKI FIVE WINNER I WELL I
. HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO WISH A MEMBER OF OUR ESTEEMED
BODY HAPPY BIRTHDAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO CENTER DRAWS- HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. MARCH SEEMS TO BE A
POPULAR BIRTHDAY MONTH IN THIS
HOUSE. MEMBERS WERE GONNA RETURN
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS IF I
CAN HAVE ALL MEMBERS TAKE THEIR
SEAT PLEASE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
INTO A GERMANS IN MEMORY. THE
MEMBERS PRESENTING A GERMAN TO
MEMORY WOULD APPRECIATE THE
ATTENDANCE THERE- ATTENTION OF
THE OF THE ALL THE MEMBERS. AND
IF WE CAN BRING PROPER
DIFFERENCE THE FLORIDA PROJECT
AT. THEIR ACTIONS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A
LEGENDARY SAN DIEGANS RETIRED
AIR FORCE BRIGADIER GENERAL
ROBERT BOB CARDENAS. HE DIED ON
MARCH TENTH AT THE VERY
COMMENDABLE AGE OF ONE HUNDRED
AND TWO. BORN ON MEXICO'S
YUCATAN PENINSULA IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE MOVED TO SAN DIEGO
WHEN HE WAS FIVE YEARS OLD. BUT
LATER ATTENDED SAN DIEGO STATE
BUT HE LEFT TO JOIN THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD TO
PURSUE HIS DREAM OF BECOMING A
PILOT. WORLD WAR TWO BROKE OUT
BOB SERVED AS A SECOND
LIEUTENANT IN THE U. S. ARMY AIR
CORPS HE FLEW B. TWENTY FOURS AS
PART OF THE FORTY FOURTH BOMB
GROUP KNOWN AS THE FLYING EIGHT
BALLS. ON HIS TWENTIETH MISSION
OVER AN AIR ARMAMENTS FACTORY IN
GERMANY HE WAS HOT DOWN AND
WOUNDED BY SHRAPNEL THAT PIERCED
HIS HELMET. BOB HAD TO SWIM
ACROSS THE LAKE AFTER THE CRASH
AND WAS SAVED FROM DROWNING BY
AN ANGLER. WHO BROUGHT INTO
NEUTRAL SWITZERLAND. WHERE HE
WAS HELD UNTIL HE SKATES WITH
THE HELP OF THE FRENCH
RESISTANCE IN NINETEEN FORTY
FOUR. AFTER WORLD WAR TWO BOMB
BECAME A TEST PILOT AND HE LATER
SERVED AS A COMMANDER OF THE
EIGHTEENTH TACTICAL FIGHTER
WING. WHICH IS DEPLOYED JET
FIGHTER SQUADRONS IN VIETNAM. I
WAS ALSO AT THE FOREFRONT OF
AEROSPACE INNOVATION. HE SERVED
AS A COMMAND PILOT OF THE
AIRCRAFT THAT FAMOUSLY LAUNCHED
CHUCK YEAGER'S BELL X. ONE INTO
SUPERSONIC FLIGHT IN NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN. IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT HE WAS PROMOTED TO
BRIGADIER GENERAL AND GIVEN
COMMAND OF THE AIR FORCE SPECIAL
OPERATIONS FORCES IN FLORIDA.
FORMER SEED MANY AWARDS AND
HONORS FOR HIS DISTINGUISHED
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY INCLUDING
HIS INDUCTION INTO THE
INTERNATIONAL AIR AND SPACE HALL
OF FAME. AND TO THE RETIRED-
MILITARY COLLEAGUES ON THIS
FLOOR YOU WILL BE INCREDIBLY
IMPRESSED AND UNDERSTAND THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF MY NEXT COMMENT
. BOB EARNED THE AIR FORCE
DISTINGUISHED SERVICE MEDAL THE
LEGION OF MERIT WITH OAK LEAF
CLUSTER THE DISTINGUISHED FLYING
CROSS PURPLE HEART. NATORI
SERVICEMEN A PRESIDENTIAL
CITATION AND NUMEROUS OTHER
AWARDS. AFTER RETIRING FROM THE
AIR FORCE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE BOB EMBRACE THE COMMUNITY
AND WORKED IN SAN DIEGO AND
SERVED ON COMMITTEES AND BOARDS
FOCUSED ON ECONOMIC GROWTH. ON
THE BORDER- JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS. BOB WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN ESTABLISHING THE
MIRAMAR NATIONAL CEMETERY IN
TWENTY TEN WHICH NOW SPANS THREE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN ACRES AND IS
THE FINAL RESTING PLACE FOR TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF VETERANS. THIS
PARTICULAR ACCOMPLISHMENT WAS SO
IMPORTANT TO BOB THAT HE WILL BE
BURIED AT MIRAMAR THIS WEEKEND
INSTEAD OF ARLINGTON NATIONAL
CEMETERY IN VIRGINIA. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF SEVENTY
FOUR YEARS GLADYS THEIR SEVEN
CHILDREN AND NINETEEN
GRANDCHILDREN I CONSIDER IT AN
INCREDIBLE HONOR THAT I GOT TO
MEET THIS INDIVIDUAL. COLLEAGUES
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
RECOGNITION OF BRIGADIER GENERAL
BOB ACCORDING. THANK YOU
SYRACUSE I JOIN YOU. I JOIN YOU
IN THAT GERMAN MEMORIES- JOE
GUARDING IT SAYS IT. ANTACID
HUMAN BEING AND A GREAT SAN
DIEGANS. NEXT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A SENATOR- IT'S
INTERACTIONS IF YOU BRING THE
NAME FORWARD SO THAT A DRUG
HARDING IS CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO
SENATOR BATES CENTER MAKES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO A JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY
OF BILL FOR BURNS WHO PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY TWELFTH AT THE
AGE OF NINETY FOUR SHE WAS AN
INFLUENTIAL HISTORIAN AND
CONSERVATIONIST BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY A BELOVED MEMBER OF
THE SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO
COMMUNITY SHE WAS BORN IN
SWITZERLAND. MOVED TO THE UNITED
STATES WHEN SHE WAS TWENTY THREE
YEARS OLD AND SOON GOT A JOB
WORKING AS A LAB TECHNICIAN AT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY HOSPITAL
DURING WHICH TIME SHE MET HER
HUSBAND. REALLY BURNS. IT'LL
FEEL FOR ANDROID MARRIED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR AND LIVED
OVERSEAS TERRITORIES TO BOYS
TIME IN THE ARMY BEFORE
SETTLING. IN SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO
THEY WERE MARRIED FOR SIXTY FOUR
YEARS OF POOR CHILDREN. YES KIM
KATHERINE AND BARBARA. YEAH THE
LIST DEALS ILSA WAS AN ADVOCATE
FOR OPEN SPACE PRESERVATION AND
LOCAL HISTORY AND WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR REGISTERING NINE
OUT OF THE THIRTEEN OF SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO PROPERTIES LISTED IN
THE NATIONAL REGISTER. OF
HISTORIC PLACES. HE STARTED THIS
JOURNEY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
WHEN SHE LED A SEVEN YEAR EFFORT
TO PLACE LOS RIOS STREET
HISTORIC. DISTRICT ON THE
REGISTER IN NINETEEN NINETY SHE
WAS SUCCESSFUL IN NOMINATING THE
HOME OF SAN CLEMENTE FOUNDER OLE
HANSON. COMMONLY KNOWN AS CASA
ROMANTICA. LAST VICTORY WAS
REGISTERING THAT. THE JUDGE
RICHARD EGAN HOUSE ON TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IN ADDITION TO HER
PASSION FOR HISTORY. HE HAD
EIGHT FOR OUTDOOR CONSERVATION
AND ONE OF HER MOST NOTABLE
CAMPAIGNS WAS THE PRESERVATION
AND RECOGNITION OF CRYSTAL COLD.
IN IN SOUTH LAGUNA. HE PUSHED
BACK AGAINST THE IRVINE COMPANY
FOR ENDING THE LEASES OF THE
FORTY SIX COTTAGES IN THE AREA
THE COTTAGES WERE BUILT IN THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES AND SOME HAD
BEEN OCCUPIED BY THIRD AND
FOURTH GENERATION FAMILIES IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE THE IRVINE
COMPANY SOLD THE LAND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. FOR ALL HER EFFORTS
TO HAVE LOCAL HISTORIC LANDMARKS
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED NOT ONCE
DID SHE EVER CHARGED THE CITY
FOR HER WORK ON TOP OF
EVERYTHING ELSE YET ACCOMPLISHED
HE LED EFFORTS TO BUILD THE
TRAIL SYSTEM THAT CONNECTS THEM
ON HILLSIDES AND OTHER TRAILS
THROUGH ORANGE COUNTY. BECAUSE
OF HER EFFORTS THE CALIFORNIA
TRAILS AND GREENWAYS FOUNDATION
AWARDED HER ITS VOLUNTEER
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. HE WAS
FLUENT IN AT LEAST FIVE
LANGUAGES INCLUDING FRENCH
ITALIAN GERMAN AND SPANISH AND
WAS THE CHAMPION SWIMMER AND HAD
A NEVER ENDING LOVE FOR ANIMALS
OF ALL SORTS. WIDELY KNOWN AS
THE BIRD LADY OF ORANGE COUNTY
HER BACKYARD WAS FILLED WITH
CAGES OF ALL SIDES ARE ALL KINDS
OF BIRDS. EVEN THOUGH SHE USED A
WALKER DURING HER LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS SHE STILL MANAGED TO STAY
INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY. AN
ATTENDED WEEKLY COMMUNITY COFFEE
CHATS ON FRIDAYS THAT INDICES
TAVERN IN IS REMEMBER TO WHAT
HAD ONCE SAID MY BODY MAY BE
GONE BUT MY BRAIN IS NOT DEAD
I'M STILL ACTIVE. ALTHOUGH SHE
IS NO LONGER WITH US HER LEGACY
WILL LIVE ON FOR YEARS TO COME
SHE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED I ASK
THAT WE ENTER INTO HER MEMORY
TODAY. AND SEND OUR CONDOLENCES
TO HER FAMILY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER BREAKS BASE IF YOU
CAN- BRING MS BURNS NOT THE NAME
FORWARD SO THAT SHE COULD BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. NEXT
WE'RE GONNA RECOGNIZE SENATOR
HERTZBERG CENTERS. PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY. YOUR HONOR THE LIFE
OF AN EXTRAORDINARY INDIVIDUAL.
A MAN MANY OF US HAVE HAD THE
GREAT PRIVILEGE OF GETTING TO
KNOW OVER THE YEARS AND SOMEONE
WHO SERVED. OUR STATE IN BOTH
THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS HIS NAME VIC
FAZIO. FOR TWENTY YEARS FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE TO
NINETEEN NINETY NINE CONGRESSMAN
VISIO REPRESENTED THE AREA JUST
WEST OF US IN WEST SAC AND YOLO
COUNTY AND SOLANO COUNTIES. MANY
OF US WHO HAVE DRIVEN ACROSS.
THE YOLO COUNTY CAUSEWAY. ON I.
EIGHTY HAVE SEEN HIS LEG ONE OF
HIS MANY LEGACIES IN PHYSICAL
FORM. A BIG SIGN THAT READS VIC
FAZIO YOLO WILDLIFE AREA. THE
MILLIONS OF DRIVERS WHO HAVE
PASSED THAT SIGN ON THE WEIGHTED
INTO SACRAMENTO. I'M REMINDED
OF. THE CONGRESSMAN'S LEGACY.
AMONG HIS MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS
IT WAS ABOUT RESTORING THE
WETLANDS BETWEEN DAVIS AND
SACRAMENTO AND ESTABLISHING THE
AREA AS A WILDLIFE REFUGE. WAS A
MONUMENTAL UNDERTAKING AND THE
MEN UNDER AMONG MANY OTHERS OF
HIS UNDERTAKINGS AT THE TIME OF
THE RIBBON CUTTING PRESIDENT
CLINTON IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
FORMALLY DEDICATED THAT AREA.
WHAT HE SAID I THINK CAPTURES
WHO RICK FACIO WAS PRESIDENT
SAID. ABOUT CONGRESSMAN FAZIO
ANY SUM THEM UP HE SAID HE IS
ONE OF THE MOST OUTSTANDING
MEMBERS THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS IN EITHER PARTY. IF WE
HAD A HUNDRED MORE LIKE HIM
AMERICA WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM.
BEYOND HIS IMPRESSIVE LEADERSHIP
ON THE ENVIRONMENT CONGRESSMAN
FABIO. WAS ACTIVE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP OF THE
UNITED STATES HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HOLDING
POSITIONS RANGING THE VICE
CHAIRMAN OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS CHAIR OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSIONAL CAMPAIGN
COMMITTEE. AT ONE POINT
CONGRESSMAN FAZIO WAS THE THIRD
HIGHEST RANKING DEMOCRAT IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES HE ALSO
SERVED AS A RANKING MEMBER OF
THE POWERFUL HOUSE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR A
TEEN YEARS. HE WAS
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AND
APPROPRIATELY KNOWN AS THE GO TO
GUY FOR CALIFORNIA IF YOU NEED
FEDERAL MONEY HE TALKED TO VIC
HE GOT IT DONE BUT MOST TIMES HE
DELIVERED FUNDING FOR PROJECTS
IN ALL CORNERS OF THE GOLDEN
STATE THE BENEFIT MILLIONS OF
FOLKS. THROUGHOUT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. ON HIS RETIREMENT HE
WORKED AS A SENIOR ADVISER TO
ONE OF THE NATION'S LARGEST LAW
FIRMS THEY CAN GO. IT ALSO
HELPED LEAD THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION
FOUNDATION AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
A RESPONSIBLE FEDERAL BUDGET.
EVERY TIME I WOULD GO TO
WASHINGTON DC OVER THE MANY
YEARS I SERVED IN GOVERNMENT AND
STOP BY AND PAID A VISIT TO THE
VIC. LISTEN TO THE STORIES GAIN
SAGE ADVICE ON HOW TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS AND- UNDERSTAND
RELATIONSHIPS BETTER. HE ALWAYS
TOOK THE TIME TO ADVISE YOUNG
PEOPLE LIKE ME AT THE TIME. AND
HELP US ALONG OUR WAY. HE WAS A
POWER HOUSE LEADER SOMEONE WE
ALL ASPIRE TO EMULATE. BUT
PERHAPS WHAT STANDS OUT TO ME
MOST ABOUT CONGRESSMAN PHASE YOU
WAS A STEADFAST DEVOTION TO OUR
NATION'S INSTITUTIONS. IT'S WHAT
EARNED HIM HIS NICKNAME. WHY
SHOP STEWARD OF THE HOUSE MAYOR
OF CAPITOL HILL MR GOODWRENCH OF
THE HOUSE HE KNEW HOW TO GET
THINGS DONE. AND HE DID IT WITH
THE UTMOST RESPECT. FOR THE
INSTITUTION. AND FOR ALL WHO
CAME BEFORE HIM. NOW MEMBERS AS
WE HONOR ONE OF THE GREATEST YOU
CAN CAME BEFORE US VIC FAZIO
MISTER GOODRICH IF YOU WILL GOOD
RANGE IF YOU WILL. NOT ONLY THE
HOUSE BUT FOR OUR TIME FUNCTION
FACE SHIELD LEAVES BEHIND HIS
WIFE. CATHERINE SAWYER IS
DAUGHTER DANA THIS TWO STEP
CHILDREN AND FOUR GRANDCHILDREN
. MEMBERS TAKE A MOMENT. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE JOURNEY IN THE
MEMORY. OF CONGRESSMAN VIC
FANGIO. THANK YOU CENTERS FOR IF
YOU'LL PLEASE BRING CONGRESSMAN
FAZIO'S NAME FORWARD TO THE DESK
SO THAT HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO SURVIVE CASKEY. IN A RISK MY
CASHIER RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TEACHER
IN THE MEMORY OF KERRY SANDOVAL
WHO LIVED IN MY DISTRICT IN
HAYWARD BUT IS KNOWN THROUGHOUT
THE BAY AREA IS A CAMPAIGN OF
WORKING PEOPLE THREE LEAVES A
MESSAGE FOR ALL OF US REMEMBER
SHE WAS AT HOME TAKING A SHOWER
AND SLIPPED AND FELL AND HIT HER
HEAD. HE DIDN'T GO TO DOCTORS
SHE WAS A TOUGH PERSON IF YOU
KNEW TERRY HE SAYS I'M OKAY I'M
WE GET GO FORWARD INTO. AND GET
MY LIFE'S WORK DONE AND SHE
PASSED AWAY. SO I PRAYED
EVERYBODY MY DAD FELT AFTERWARDS
AND WE RUSHED HIM TO THE
HOSPITAL NINETY FOUR. BUT THE
LESSON IS THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
THESE HEAD INJURIES SERIOUSLY.
SHE WORKED AS AN ORGANIZER FOR
NUMEROUS LOCAL CAMPAIGNS FOR
CANDIDATES AND ISSUES THROUGHOUT
THE EAST BAY HE ATTENDED THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF THE ARTS.
AND WORKED AS AN OPERATING
ENGINEER. WHEN IT WASN'T COOL
FOR A WOMAN TO BE AN OPERATING
ENGINEER BUT ONE OF THE FEW
WOMEN. WHO'S WHO AT THE TIME WHO
WERE RUNNING THOSE THAT BIG
EQUIPMENT ON CONSTRUCTION SITES.
HE WENT ON TO BECOME AN
ORGANIZER WITH SEIU U. L. T. C.
W. EN THE ESKI ARE YOU UNITED
HEALTHCARE WORK. PREVIOUSLY SHE
WORKED. AS A THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
LABOR. COUNCIL AT THE TIME FOR
PASSING SHE WAS SERVING AS THE
CHAIR OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY-
DEMOCRATIC OF. PARTY AND WAS
ACTIVE FOR MANY YEARS WITH THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S POLITICAL
CAUCUS CAUCUS IF YOU CAN SEE SHE
WAS. HAD HER FINGERS EVERYWHERE
BUT HER MAIN PASSION. WAS TO
EMPOWER AND ADVOCATE FOR LOW
WAGE WORKERS. HE OFTEN BROUGHT
MANY OF US ON THE FLOOR TO
RALLIES AT KAISER.
ORGANIZATIONAL MEETINGS AND
EMPLOYEES ON THE FRONT LINE OF
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND
ADVOCATED FOR LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD RAISE THE FLOOR. BUT LABOR
STANDARDS FOR THOSE OF LOW WAGE
WORKERS HI IN OUR STATE HE WILL
BE REMEMBERED AS A PASSIONATE
FIGHTER- YES BUT ALSO AS A WARM
AND LOVING FRIEND TO MANY OF US.
I ASK MEMBERS THAT WE RETURN. IN
THE MEMORY OF TERRY SANDOVAL.
THEIR SCANNER ON THIS ITEM.
THEIR SKIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ALSO ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
TERRY SANDOVAL BEFORE SHE WAS MR
WHITE BECAUSE HIS CONSTITUENTS
SHE WAS MINE BUT MORE THAN THAT.
TERRY SANDOVAL AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FREMONT MENTIONED WAS VERY
VERY ACTIVE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AS A LABOR ORGANIZER IN
THE NATIONALIST POLITICAL CAUCUS
AND SO MUCH MORE BUT SHE ALSO
WAS THE CAMPAIGN MANAGER FOR MY
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT ASSEMBLY
CAMPAIGN. HE WAS A BELOVED
MOTHER A CARE GIVER FRIEND A
FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR THE RIGHTS
OF WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
WORKERS. AND WHEN SHE MOVED TO
THE EAST BAY IN THE NINETY SHE
BURST INTO THE POLITICAL SCENE.
HE SHOWED UP ONE DAY AT A BOARD
MEETING OF THE ALUM MEET AT THE
NORTHERN ALAMEDA COUNTY CHAPTER
OF NW PC. AND SHE STARTED. TO
ORGANIZE THE PROTECTIONS OF OUR
CLINICS BECAUSE THERE WERE- ANTI
ABORTION PROTESTERS AT THEM AND
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE NEEDING TO
GET CARE AT THE CLINICS WERE
INTIMIDATED. SHE ORGANIZED
PEOPLE TO SHOW UP AND WE WOULD
HAVE TO SHOW UP REGULARLY WE
SIGNED UP FOR HOURS FOR THE
CLINIC WATCH- SHE EAGERLY
RECRUITING CAMPAIGN FOR PRO
CHOICE WOMEN SHE WAS THE FIRST
LATINA BOARD MEMBER AT NW PC.
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM FREMONT
MENTIONED HE WAS IN THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS AND SHE WAS
ONE OF THE FEW. VERY FEW FEMALE
MEMBERS OF THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS AND SHE TOOK PRIDE IN
DRIVING AN ENORMOUS EARTH MOVING
MACHINE. TO BUILD THAT THEN NEW
SFO TERMINAL. WHEN HER BELOVED
SON JOSEPH ARRIVED IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE HE CARRIED THEM TO
CAMPAIGN MEETINGS AND EVENTS IN
THE BABY CARRIER IN CHILE
OUTGREW IT. HE VOLUNTEERED ON MY
CAMPAIGN- HE WAS SO PROUD OF THE
MAN AND THE MUSICIAN THAT HE'S
NOW BECOME. AN EVERYBODY IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WHO KNEW TERRY
ALSO KNEW ALL ABOUT JOSEPH AND
THE VARIOUS INSTRUMENTS YOU
PLAYED AND HIS SUCCESSES NOW- HE
WAS A DEVOTED CARE GIVER TO HER
DEAR MOTHER WHO SPENT MANY YEARS
IN THE FOG OF DEMENTIA HE WAS A
LOYAL FRIEND TO MANY A SKILLED
POLITICAL ADVISER THE FEARLESS
AND ON WAVERING ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN FOR CHILDREN FOR WORKING
FAMILIES AND SHE LEFT THIS WORLD
A BETTER AND MORE EQUITABLE
PLACE. HE WILL BE MISSED AND IT
IS MISSED IMMENSELY AND I ASK
THAT WE ARE TURNING HER MEMORY
AND CARRY ON THE FIGHT. THANK
YOU SENATORS IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
BRING THIS ANIMAL'S NAME FOUR TO
THE DESK SO THEY CAN SHE SHE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. MEMBERS
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ACTIONS THE DESK IS CLEAR
. KELLY THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
MISTER PRESIDENT THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS
THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT NINE AM
THANK YOU CENTER ACTIONS. BEFORE
WE ADJOURN I'LL REMIND MEMBERS
THAT WE HAVE COMMITTEE HEARINGS
THIS AFTERNOON SO PLEASE. WATCH
YOUR CALENDARS TO MAKE SURE
YOU'RE IN THE PROPER HEARING
ROOM AT THE PROPER TIME FOR THE
PROPER. COMMITTEE AND WITH THAT
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS AND
I'M SORRY. I DON'T HAVE IT ON
THE- WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS MY
APOLOGIES. AND WE RECKON SPURS.
COMMITTEE ON LABOR. SIR CORTESE
THIS SHOULD BE A- THE PRESIDENT-
THE COMMITTEE ON NON LABOR-
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
WILL MEET FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER
GERMAN IN THE SWING SPACE IN
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU SWING SPACE TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. CENTER LAMONT. HERE THE
COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND FINANCE
WILL MEET FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER
A POP UP UPON THE JUDGMENT IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED IN THE-
STREET BUILDING THANK YOU ONE
HUNDRED DOES G. O. STREET
BANKING AND FINANCE AND THE
FINAL COMMITTEE TODAY. THERE ARE
A NUMBER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF THE BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE AND WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
THE SWING SPACE THANK YOU.
REMEMBER REMEMBER. ONE HUNDRED
TWELVE HUNDRED. OKAY THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM.
THURSDAY AT NINE AM.